i think at the end of the day you need
to be very very careful
not to get in love with the technology
but have a technology that
solves a real problem
[Music]
all right jorge mishni thank you so much
for joining us on 20 minute leaders
thank you thank you for having me so
great to have you we know each other
from the j ventures fund
and you know i i just love how i get to
meet all these incredible people
uh through the through this capitalistic
kibbutz and
you have a fascinating story which which
i can't wait
to hear on this show about your journey
from uruguay to israel to the u.s
the startup that you sold to qualcomm
and your
your amazing work at intel and on wi-fi
and things that i have no idea about
and uh and finally about your your new
startup which
as you mentioned you're grinding on
which which i love jorge
who are you give me give me the round
down
okay so originally i was born in
uruguay in south america and then got
married and moved to israel
when i was uh 26
and started started to work at intel
at the wi-fi team at intel and when i
got there
we were kind of a small startup inside
intel
so i think we were about 30 people
and then fast forward 2007
i i left
to start my my first startup and uh
we were about 1500 i think karinto
at that time on the wi-fi team and you
know after the centrino and after the
the
the whole revolution of wi-fi and
went with the other three uh partners
and we started weight velocity there was
a
60 gigahertz wi-fi chipset company and
together with that company in 2010 so i
moved to the bay area to start the
operations here in the bay area
and then 2014 qualcomm acquired us
the transition from uruguay to israel
not that common
uh going straight into intel what was
that about so you get married and you
decide to just move your whole life
to israel yeah actually yeah
so i started in in ukraine i did
my undergrad and and second degree
master's degree there and
i always wanted to go to israel and move
to israel
so i had the opportunity when i was a
team
to go and because uruguay's in the south
so the the uh
scholar year is the opposite right
so when i was about to start in israel
so i
i already did half a year in in
college in uruguay you know it's
just a bunch of uh excuses why not but
then i said okay well i
already started so let's do it here etc
so bottom line i i just finished there
and that was the next stage and the next
the next phase when i could say
okay that's the time so with my
current wife so we said okay let's go so
actually we got married
and a month later we were in israel
sleeping on
on uh eating on the floor
wonderful and you joined intel you
joined the wi-fi team during the wi-fi
revolution what was that like
working on technologies that really
shape
how we how we interface with the world
today especially
you know my generation yeah it was
it was great right i think it was a it
was a great
journey and and coming from a big
company
and seeing how that evolved
it it was great so it started with kind
of one megabit per second
and it was kind of a big revolution just
to get one more per second
and and then it becomes that great thing
with all the operation at some point
we were i was in charge of one of
the generations and you know we were
manufacturing 50 million chipsets a year
and it was really great and when when
intel decided to go all in
with the centrino and make the wi-fi
part of the branding of the centrino and
getting
at that time was mcdonald's getting hot
spots in mcdonald's because
of course you need both sides and that
was
great and just going everywhere and you
know just the pride of going
somewhere and say ah that is the chief
that i designed
that was pretty fun amazing amazing okay
and then and then from there you get
you you go with a few partners and you
move on to velocity
and there you you develop technology
that you actually sell to qualcomm right
yeah one and so what was that like
moving from a huge corporation like
intel and going to create a startup uh
which is you said
60 gigahertz yeah so
the way wi-fi works you know it's in the
bands there
are are free ism bands so 2.4 and 5
gigahertz are bands that
everybody can use and at some point the
fcc's of the world uh
just took 60 abandoned around 60
gigahertz
and said okay this band is now ism
and the reason for that is because of
the the size of the molecules of oxygen
so there is more absorption
than even in higher frequencies so
basically nobody wants to use it
it's a it's it's not a good frequency to
use because of there is a lot of noise
loss so that's why they said okay you
know what
whoever wants to use it can use it and
that's where we said
okay we need to use it for indoor so not
very long range but because of the
the real estate that you have there the
bandwidth that you have there
so you can go very very wide that means
very very fast so our first product was
uh 4.6 gigabits per second
and wow and today
it laid the spec also all the way to 100
gigabits per second
wirelessly incredible incredible and
then what and then what were you doing
at qualcomm so
when we were acquired uh
by qualcomm so basically uh a couple of
years
earlier qualcomm acquired another
company called
atheros that
was the big uh wi-fi
and became a big communications company
not just wi-fi at some point
so when they acquired uh atheros
actually they became kind of the
communications group
inside qualcomm so when we were acquired
we merged into the uh the atheros group
and basically took over the
products of weight velocity inside
qualcomm and
just merge into the communications team
and
build the whole combo of
wi-fi and yd that is the name of the 60
gigahertz technology
etc wow that's a very very interesting
and now
fast forward to today you're you're
acting both as an
angel investor as part of j vendors but
you're also running
your own company i'd love to hear about
this tension
between these two things so on one hand
we meet on a monthly basis before
physically now virtually
to look at different startups and
different opportunities yet
you yourself are acting the same role
as the entrepreneurs were evaluating so
so
what is the how does that play out it's
actually kind of funny because sometimes
you are on one side of the table
and others you are on the other side of
the table so
you you learn to actually you learn
a lot from being on both sides of the
table of course so you know
as i mean as an entrepreneur right when
you
act as the vc
right uh so you understand
what they are looking for right so you
know how to sell
your ph better on one side on the flip
side
you know you understand also the the guy
that is coming and preaching to you
probably for the first usually uh j
adventures for the for the first time of
the first uh
initial uh uh
so you try to actually you try to help
them
right so i find myself a lot of times
uh just whether we decide to invest
as a fun or myself personally
just helping them and it happened in
several cases
for example one of the companies that we
have that
could have a relationship in south
america
so i connected them with some companies
that i know
and try to get them going right so
you appreciate much more ball size
right and well you use the use the intel
that you get on both sides when you're
on the other side 100 and
i i'm getting so much um you know
insight and inspiration
myself coming in as a student i'm you
know an engineer
but i and and i'm going to be an
entrepreneur hopefully soon
and hopefully pitching to funds and
angel groups like j
ventures and i think that
you know there's the just understanding
the questions that are being asked
it's so phenomenal and it's it's really
humbling
to see how many different things you can
think of
and what are the common pitfalls and and
how much you can learn
from every single person and like i'm
learning from you
through j ventures so it's really really
great and chameleon talk to me a little
bit about that
so chameleon is the the latest one so
after
i took the latest adventure yeah so i
took some time off
uh after a long time that i was
grinding uh i i took some time off
uh spent some time with the family and
we had a
great uh road trip across the
across the u.s from coast to coast
so at some point i said okay now it's
time to go back to
the trenches so uh
actually we i i partner with two
other guys one of them is also a guy
that uh that i work with that
velocity and we started convenient
that we are trying to solve the the
cyber security problem
but from the foundation so there is a
lot of
uh there's a lot of companies in there
working on the on the cyber space but
we we see that
basically at the end of the day all the
software runs on top of
hardware and that hardware was never
designed
for security so it's a patch on top of a
patch on top of a patch
and what we see is that unless you build
a strong base it doesn't matter what you
build on top at the end of the day you
can always
come underneath right so so this is what
we are doing and basically
chameleon is building what we call the
spo it's a security processing unit
that is a companion device to any system
but in particular
right now we are working on on pcs and
servers
and protect the system from time zero so
all the boot of the system
and then during runtime and isolates
completely
the the
attackers from the defenders and gives a
very secure environment for the
defenders
where they can trust and trust here is a
big
big word they can trust what they see
right they cannot be fooled
and they get full visibility on the
system
how it's working and what's going on is
that why it's called chameleon because
it can change its color and
it's color based on what you want it to
so that it blends with the environment
yeah so one of the applications that we
are also doing is
what it's called moving target defense
and basically what you do is you change
the memory map of the of the software
that is running
in runtime so that's where the comedian
is coming we move things around
so when attacker wants to attack the
system they don't know where
basically where the entrance is right so
you are moving
the windows and the doors all the time
right so when they try to get into the
house and
they don't know where to enter from
right now
that makes a lot of sense and i have to
ask so
you know going from corporate to
startup to corporate to now investor
what what are some things that that
you're that you're bringing with you
into this newest venture because you're
you you must be approaching this
with a little bit more insight if not a
lot more insight than you had before
so what are some of you know the key
things that you and your partner
set out and you know you knew off the
bat that perhaps a
jorge of velocity in its early days
didn't know
um i think that uh working on both
sides on small companies and on big
companies you
you understand the motivations
behind what people do at the end of the
day you deal with people
yeah you do business with people right
doesn't matter if it's
intel qualcomm velocity small big medium
it's all the same at the end of the day
you need to try
and understand what is uh
driving that person what is the level of
risk
that it's willing to take and why
and so having worked in
big companies small companies usually
americans but
doesn't doesn't necessarily need to be
right
you get to at least
understand or recognize what are the
things that
drive people what is the all the
internal especially in the corporate so
the internal politics
right at the corporate and who are the
the right people to talk to what is that
you need to offer find the the person
that can help you
you know i think it's i think it's so
cool that you're dealing with you know
the very low level of technology very
hardcore technology
and yet when i ask you about the things
that you're taking with you from your
previous experiences you're not
saying i'm taking more knowledge and
more expertise in the domain but you're
saying
i'm taking the understanding that at the
end it's all about people and it's all
about relationships
right yeah at the end of the day i mean
even though it's still silicon and
semiconductor right i was doing
communications now it's security
systems so it's uh
the expertise you know you can always
find good people
and build a good team but at the end of
the day
you need to know how to build the whole
system
especially when you are trying to change
some conventions
right when when i talk about cyber
security nobody thinks about hardware
everybody thinks about software
antivirus or
whatever right so just
shifting making that part
time shift it's not trivial
and at the end of the day you need to
find the right people that are
willing to take that leap of faith
with you and and the risk of course
right and say okay we need to fix this
from the foundation we need to build the
right foundation
and it's not another feature and if it's
white or black
or whatever right are there are there
more you know
and you know i'm trying to think of
things that i would
want to take for myself as i approach my
own ventures later on
and my own experience as in the tech
industry what what are some of the
earned secrets that you've accumulated
over the years
in terms of you know the the products
that you're building
and and communicating with customers and
with different people
um i think about at the end of the day
you need to be very very careful
not to get in love with the technology
but having a technology that
solves a real problem okay so the
technology is the consequence and not
the cost
right so you need to be very very
careful
as a technical people we always fall in
love with the technology
of course but at the end of the day when
you go to a potential customer
you need to understand their pain and
see how the technology
solves their pain and not just well this
is cool
right this technology is really cool uh
so i think that this is uh probably the
main thing
uh in terms of
what you do with the with your things
when
and and being out front i think it's the
other one you know as a startup you are
always
with the less resources that you want
and you are always
probably promising a little bit more
than what you really have
and it's kind of a leap of
faith also there so while
i think it's okay and it's uh everybody
understands that
you need to be very very upfront you
don't want to put
your potential customers and your
champions inside the company
in a bad position so you need to be very
very open and develop
that uh relationship with them so
they know what they have and they can
help you manage that
and navigate the the company they know
that better than you
i love it i love it we almost have to
end but i have to ask you my favorite
question
uh three words that you would use to
describe yourself
or that your co-founders from either
startup would use to describe you as
three words uh three words
adventurous okay i've
been going up and down
right and left and things that i didn't
know exactly how they would end
great okay uh
and you know sometimes people always ask
me
why i left a big corporate with a big
salary
right and go back to the trenches but
that's what i like and
the third one i think it's um citizen of
the world
uh having i've been lived in three
countries now and
at least 10 years and on each you get a
little bit of each one
with you and you are always missing a
i love it i love it wonderful okay thank
you so much for the inspiration and for
the time i really appreciate it
and uh and best of luck with chameleon
great happy to be here thank you